[موسيقى]
بعد سنوات من التحضير ،
تفصل طوكيو 2020 بعد أسابيع قليلة
عن موعدها بسبب تأخر عام واحد بسبب
قول منظمي الوباء إن الحدث سيكلف الآن
15.4 مليار دولار ، وتشير بعض التقديرات
إلى
أنه سيكلف أكثر بكثير.
من الجمهور
يريد إلغاء الألعاب ، لقد حظرت اليابان بالفعل
المتفرجين في الخارج والتي يقدر معهد نامورا
للأبحاث
أنها ستكلف البلاد أكثر من
مليار دولار في الإيرادات المفقودة
لإلغاء الألعاب التي تقول إنها ستكلف
أكثر من 16 مليار دولار
لكن مركز الأبحاث يحذر من أن هذه
التكاليف في الواقع  شاحب
مقارنة بالضرر الاقتصادي ، قد تتسبب موجة أخرى من
فيروس كورونا في أن تتسبب
اللجنة الدولية في أن أولويتها هي الاحتفاظ
بألعاب آمنة
ومأمونة ، وبينما يتصاعد الضغط على اليابان
لإلغاء الألعاب
تعاقديًا ، لا يمكن ذلك عند
ممارسة الكيان الوحيد الذي يمكنه
إلغاء الألعاب هي
اللجنة الأولمبية الدولية IOC
لأنه وفقًا للميثاق الأولمبي ،
فإن ioc لها حق حصري  هناك
ممتلكات للألعاب ، وهذا يعني أنه في الواقع
لا يمكن لليابان أن تقرر من جانب واحد إلغاء
الألعاب الأولمبية
إذا كانت اليابان إذا قررت اللجنة
المنظمة إذا قررت طوكيو
عدم الاستمرار في التزاماتها
بموجب عقد المدينة بالكامل ، أه
بالطبع سيكون الأمر كذلك  ليس من الممكن
القيام بالألعاب وفي هذه
الحالة بالطبع يحق لـ rsc
مضغ تلك الأطراف المشاركة في عقد المدينة المضيفة ،
فإن ioc لديها تأمين لإلغاء الألعاب
والتخلي عنها
والذي يمكن أن يغطي جزءًا من
تكلفتها التشغيلية ولكن ماذا عن شركائها
الرعاة والمذيعون الأهم من حيث المال هو التلفاز
صحيح العقود المختلفة الآن
معقدة للغاية أه قبل 20 عامًا
كان من السهل جدًا الإجابة على سؤالك
اليوم إنه مستحيل إلى حد ما
لأن شبكات التلفزيون المختلفة أه
كلاهما ليس كذلك  ألعاب واحدة فقط ولكن عدة ألعاب
تتحدث بشكل عام ثلاثة عبر الإنترنت في
بعض الأحيان أربعة ،
يتعين علينا أخذ كل عقد واحدًا تلو الآخر
وتحليل ما هو مكتوب في
الخداع  المسالك في بعض الأحيان يتم كتابته
أه شيء عن الإلغاء
عليهم أن يعوضوا ما لم يفعلوا
ذلك يعتمد على العقد وهو اتفاق تعاقدي خالص
بين شركتين خاصتين
دعاوى قضائية بمليارات الدولارات
ومطالبات التأمين معرضة للخطر إذا
تم إلغاء الألعاب
إذا ذهبوا  في المستقبل ، تخاطر اللجنة الأولمبية الدولية بخرق
ميثاقها الخاص
الذي ينص على أنها ستروج للرياضة الآمنة
وتحمي الرياضيين
الذين بدأوا بالفعل في الوصول إلى
اليابان
، ويمكن أن يتحمل التكلفة النهائية
أولئك المعرضون لخطر الإصابة بكوبت 19
إذا أصبحت طوكيو 2020
حدثًا
فائقًا للتوزيع آنا ستيوارت CNN  لندن